[Music]
are we at the beginning of a great
Christian Revival uh we're about to
celebrate Christmas which is of course
uh a Christian celebration but we are
generally I think it's acknowledged
living in a post-religious
post-christian anyway um society and
West who joins me now um has a very
interesting piece in the magazine uh
about the the headline is the new
theists um and that is a play uh on the
against the new atheists who were the
popular intellectual movement of the
2000s um Ed joins me with Mary
Harrington of unheard um Ed let's start
with you what is the thesis of your uh
piece just sum it up for our viewers
well um my argument is that in the last
20 years there's been a massive decline
in religion I mean religion's been
declining for a while but especially in
the US where religious uh attendance and
belief has hugely dropped since about
2000 um and that sort of came at the
time the new atheist movement was very
fashionable pointing that religion was
responsible for all these social evils
um christop hit's you know famous line
religion poisons everything was was the
sort of the best one but um there has
also been kind of range of new studies
and books um social science data
suggesting that religion actually has a
lot of social benefits um in terms of
well-being low
anxiety sort of community sense but also
Christianity in particular had a sort of
hugely beneficial effect on the west and
there are sort of so I saw mention a of
range of books as Jonathan Height's um
The Righteous Mind was probably the the
first one Tom Holland's dominions been
very influential um there's also Joseph
henrik's um the weirdest people in the
world which is particularly about how
Christianity uh shaped modern liberalism
and none of these people are believers
um but I mean the question is um that I
sort of wonder about is whether people
can actually sort of get the benefits of
religion without believing or whether
also they can actually sort of meme
themselves into believing if people if
enough people sort take part in in
religious events and observant then they
will start to believe which I think is
is probably possible explain a little
bit what you mean by meme because it's a
it's a term popularized or coined
possibly by Richard Dawkins isn't it of
course who was the uh the biggest new
atheist of them all yeah it was come
from the uh the the selfish Gene um and
uh he's he you know describes a meme a
meme is like an idea that spreads uh and
it it can be positive it can be negative
but it has sort of benefit to um the
person who spreads it um
and you know memes like religion is a
sort popular meme it's an idea that sort
of spreads almost like a contagion and
we sort of see in politics now I mean
lots of political sort of fashional
ideas spread um just by sort of
repetition or sort of social networks
and obviously social media makes this
much more extreme and I think that's one
reason why politics has kind of
radically shifted since smartphones have
come along because it's just so much
more possible to spread ideas even kind
of quite insane ideas um over
uh over a huge population but I always
you know so but you can also the you can
use phrases often you know people meme
themselves into some they sort of adapt
adopt a belief um partly because all
their friends do and they might even do
it ironically or they might even sort of
experiment an idea and then they
eventually sort of torque themselves
into actually adopting a sort of a
Viewpoint or a wellview um or religion
um and I think you know human beings are
obviously capable of doing this people
mean themselves into all sorts of things
well Mary um uh prayer is obviously uh
similar to Ming in a way isn't it
because it's it's sort of repetition
endless repetition um and I think it's
fair to say in America there has been
this revival of or there certainly a
Revival of interest in traditional
Christianity um is it becoming a fashion
is is it a is it a new trend do you
think that is
emerging there are definitely people who
seem attracted to the Aesthetics more or
more than they're particularly
interested in the theology I mean and
and there's there's an unmistakable
Trend at least in in certain minority
quarters for so tweeting from Mass um
which is sort of ambiguous in terms of
how it relates to actual religious
devotion um but I think I I think the
important thing is that at least when at
the the Heyday of observant Christianity
in the west it's almost certainly the
case that more people were observant
regular church attenders and so on than
really believed in in any sort of deeply
felt sense and you know and there's a
there's there's a sense in which this
idea that the the the truly the the
truly passionate Faith should precede
the worship is a very Protestant idea
you know it's a very sort of
post-reformation idea that says you know
you need to have this personal
relationship with God you know mediated
only by the Bible and that if if that
isn't if if that isn't coming to you
with a burning force of Revelation then
you're doing it wrong and maybe you
should do something else or like not go
to church um whereas the perhaps the
older preliterate relationship to the
faith was that it was just something
that you do um I'm I'm quoting a
friend's grandmother who said that a
friend who said that her grandmother was
the the real traditional catholic so not
these types who tweet from Mass and you
know ostentatiously have encourage their
girlfriends to wear the veil or whatever
um but the the actual traditional
Catholics um because they only went she
she said her grandmother was a real Trad
cath because she only went to mass twice
a year and she believed in
fairies um Ed you talk about these new
the
uh and they are they do seem to be um
sort of people who were perhaps uh quite
a few of them were uh either part of the
new new atheist movement or are liberals
who are just slightly alarmed at what
the secular world is doing um to us I
wonder just to be a bit um cynical about
it I wonder you know all those new
atheist books sold very very well um is
it quite as popular a movement or is it
more of a sort of online intellectual
phenomenon that hasn't really reached
the masses um I don't think there
anything like as popular I mean the god
illusion sold vast amounts wasn't it I
mean new
atheism was was fashionable and it's
succeeded in part because of people
sorts of people were very influenced by
what they peers and the people look up
to think and do and people tend to um
follow those things so I mean uh coming
up the argument is oh actually
Christianity produced liberalism and
Christianity is really good and you know
maybe even we should sort of you know
take part in some of the sort of Rights
of it is is nothing like it's not going
to be anything like as fashionable um or
popular and I think it's probably more
kind of countercultural in the sense
that new atheism like to present itself
as this kind of rebellion against the
mainstream but it was you know it was
very much pushing an Open Door religion
religious decline was in huge you know
it was already happening anyway amongst
the educated um all over the Western
world I mean it was partly motivated by
S fear of Islam but they didn't it was
sort of impolite to say
and it was definitely like you know
provoked partly by two um 9/11 um but
actual Christianity was in such decline
it was actually sort of going with the
grain of popular thought um I think
saying that actually Christianity is
good is very much Against the Grain um
in a s way I mean I do think
particularly like Tom Holland's book for
example uh I mean Tom you know he says
he's not a Believer and he s grew up but
he grew up in a kind of Christian
environment and and he cherishes that
and I think with um a lot of people
whose parents would have been religious
and they grew up vaguely and are kind of
occasionally going to church and the the
level of um secularization amongst their
own children is much more extreme um and
there is definitely a sort feeling of
loss because once that goes all sorts of
other kind of all sorts of other things
go you know the kind of common Cultural
Literacy I think even the sort you know
the idea of forgiveness which is I think
it is kind of counterintuitive and I
think now we're sort of learning that
and our political our kind of kind of
cultural environment is very not into
forgiveness anymore I mean you know the
council culture thing is very
much you know not Christian in that
sense and and there is a sense of of
loss really no I was want just to add to
Ed's point about the new atheists and
the mass secularization of society I
wonder if one of the things go that's
going on is that we we are now a more
secular culture than not um but the
predictions the new atheist predic about
what would happen when we all became a
secular culture have manifestly not been
delivered you know they promised a new
golden age of rationality where
everybody would be sensible like Richard
Dawkins and that's manifestly not what
what secularization has delivered and as
you know we now live in a culture of
mass unbelief but the world is more
insane than ever and in a sense it's
more it's more suffused with religiosity
than ever it's just a very untrammeled
and very chaotic and sometimes very
unwisely directed kind of religiosity
and people pour into all bizarre Cults
and um personal fitness and and you know
agnostic beliefs about about their own
physical bodies and yeah all kinds of
all kinds of bizarre things which have
taken on the same sort of mantle of a
mantle of faith that was once sort of
convened and corraled in a more
structured Way by by a mass religious
practice and I think it's it's po I
think maybe not everybody most people
just prefer to mind their own business
but amongst people who think about
things um it's becoming increasingly
obvious that it's not possible not to be
religious you know that's just that's
just how human societies function and it
really is a question of picking picking
which one and I and I suspect that you
know among again amongst you know some
more reflective often often quite young
people they've come to the conclusion
that perhaps an embodied
Redemptive forgiving kind of a religious
Faith might be superior to some of the
other options out there and and
adjusting their behavior accordingly and
in a sense I think well you know if
you're even if you're going to even you
why why why would it not be possible to
work backwards from that to to some to
some the more sort of protestant coded
mystical forms of belief that seems
eminently possible to me there's no
obvious reason why somebody should come
to a come to you arrive at the road The
Bu the start of the road to Damascus one
way or another so well I don't know but
I think I think it's it's just so
obvious that Dawkins was wrong about
what would happen when everyone stopped
believing that people people are taking
practical action well I think uh
chesteron said when people stop
believing in God they'll start believing
in anything do you think Ed we're now
seeing people stop believe people are
stopping to believe in anything and now
perhaps starting to believe in
God um no I mean I do think it's still a
small um kind of online thing but I mean
these things might have the germs of you
know the the seeds of the future uh I
mean I think in in the sort of the
irrationality thing it's you know
Dawkins who I you know sort of respect
and kind of love in a way I think you
he's come across he's he's one of the
few members of the new atheist movement
who has really sort of kept his
credibility um and he's been sort of
long ostracized because you know he is
sort of a deeply rational highly
intelligent person and most people
aren't and you know um you know the the
the fact that a lot of the new atheist
movement then pivoted towards kind of
progressivism it became new atheis plus
and it was kind of combating you know
racism and sexism and transphobia and
all these things and it ended up sort of
adopting very like religious like um
ideas about the world and you know in
particularly on the transgender issue
where there is a kind of incredible
intolerance about anyone who who
disbelieves in this um you know so it s
went from sort of transation to
transgenderism within a very short space
of time I mean I was even at the time I
think I was quite cynical about D you
know this kind of rational future but it
happened much quicker than I think
anyone really expected it became um as
Mary says like very religious likee um
but whether you know
whether I mean the problem with sort of
meing yourself back into Christianity is
you mention it is a very strange
religion in many ways it's very
counterintuitive it's much more sort of
Miracle uh orientated than other
religions um you know especially so
Islam for example so in a way it's kind
of almost like the hardest one to
embrace because it's and its ideas are
so against our kind of instincts in many
ways Mary Ed mentioned the fear of Islam
earlier I mean with with that was
certainly a driver for the new atheism
because it was after 911 and um sort of
terrorism becoming a a huge problem uh
Islamic terrorism becoming a huge
problem um do you think that perhaps the
Revival of Christianity will also come
even though again it will be impolite to
say so in polite Society uh will also
come from a fear of Islam because people
are looking at um just you know the sh
demographics of it and we can see that
secular culture uh will probably be
overwhelmed by a religious culture uh
and in the west or in brit and it could
well be Islam honestly I think I think
it's unlikely that anybody is going to
be be inspired to A Renewed flourishing
of Christian faith just because they
don't they don't want more Muslims in
their area that just seems implausible
to me and not not to mention not to
mention somewhat incompatible with with
at least the the sort of generally
received understanding of what a
Christian mindset is supposed to look
and feel like um I mean it's it's not
it's not impossible but it seems it
seems to me more um that where where
people feel themselves under threat from
a competing ideology they don't then
adopt a new ideology in order to C
combat it they double down on the one
they currently have so I mean I I I
imagine I a more plausible head-to-head
confrontation I can imagine which is
actually cropping up already in some
parts of America is is a head-on
confrontation between strict Islam and
um gender ideology and and and all the
and all that sails within it you know
the The Wider um the the the the the the
greater the greater Church of of of the
rainbow um which which is obviously
obviously at an at a some considerable
angle to observant Islam not least on
claiming that men can be women and so on
which is just obviously obviously
incompatible with with Muslim
traditional sex segregation and you're
already seeing you're already vifer
arguments um in for example in I think I
believe there was a school somewhere in
in the Midlands where where there was a
very strong parent push back against a
new curriculum that was that was brought
in on sex education which included a lot
of gender ideology and there have been
there have been um there have been
parents on the streets around some
American schools in heavily Muslim
immigrant communities in America where
they're resisting resisting this this
kind of teaching and I think and and if
you if you see if you see the Church of
rainbow as a church which I mean as as
Ed has described in some respects it
sort of is you I mean the the idea that
that humans can change sex is so
obviously factually false that if you
believe it to be true you can only be
thinking of it in some sort of
allegorical metaphorical spiritual sense
essentially um and and if you if if
you're looking at them as two two
competing accounts of what a person is
you at a fundamental level then I I see
I see that as a much more plausible
confrontation I mean in my view
political Christianity is probably toast
at I mean perhaps not forever but at
least for the for the immediate and
perhaps the foreseeable future I don't
think it's I don't think it's toasters
of Faith but I think political
Christianity in the form that's been so
dominant in the West for some centuries
is probably it's it's probably destined
for a period in in the Wilderness at
this point Ed you touched on that in in
your piece where you said that well-off
people replace religion with politics
and by that I assume you mean in large
part what Mary's talking about the you
know radical progressivism as a sort of
Article of
Faith uh yes I mean if you look at
surveys um American liberals I I don't
know about in the UK but they they place
I think like one in three Place great
emphasis on their Politics as you know
been very important to them and it's
something like 10% amongst conservatives
so it's much more on the left um you
know people need some sort of moral like
load star that they and where it's not
religion it will be some sort of like
left centered um kind of worldview um I
I think on the on the Islam thing it's
kind of it's it's slightly unknown
because what you're looking at is sort
of three-way culture wars between
progressives and conservatives and Islam
um and and so when it's kind of that
complex we're not sure
um sort of who's fighting who I mean
even stuff like you know the British
values stuff which was sort brought in
in the uh after the sort of terrorism of
the 2000s that was sort of basically
people on the left using Islam as a kind
of tool to sort of you know to win
arguments against their conservative
Rivals because it was basically just
making like British values were
basically Progressive values um and it
make kind of like an unknown factor when
you have a sort of new group who comes
in
um uh who have you know who might be
used by one side to further their own
kind of agender but they obviously have
their own beliefs and they have their
own kind of idea of what the the world
would like to be which might not
particularly fit in with the lefts I'm
not entirely sure that Islam won't I
mean I've become much more of the view
that um Islam will also basically come
be undermined heavily by progressivism
by you know secularism I mean amongst
Young younger uh Muslims um in Britain
and and West generally I think a lot of
them are um very much adopting the kind
of same political
ideas as other people um I mean all this
depends on also Geo like geopolitical
factors might changes I mean obviously
if they War when when people can adopt
you know people's religious identity can
become much more important to them in
you know in the face of conflict well we
and we've seen that with Gaza haven't we
yeah I mean the last yeah last few weeks
obviously it becomes hugely important to
people who might not have been thinking
about it that much I mean there was
actually I mean the question about
people's religious Faith there was I
remember there was Data a while back
showing that in England where there was
a large Muslim population a large number
of local white British people did
identify as Christian even if they
didn't actually go to church so it
obviously became uh more of an important
identity to them um not enough to
actually you know get back in the swing
of things but you you know religion has
always been you know very linked to sort
of ethnic identity in many many
different places you know around the
world so it's not impossible that it
could become a kind of locust for kind
of identity conflict in the future the
the Church of rainbow expressivism is
now is increasingly strongly us Imperial
coded um I mean the we we only have to
think about the the the US Embassy
flying the pride flag at the Vatican or
you know the the the immediate jump from
with of Afghan withdrawal to you know
what what's what's going to happen to
the LGBT minorities there and they and
the and the sense in you know this the
the the the sheer volume of video
content that came out of Ukraine in the
first in the first few weeks of that
conflict which focused on Ukraine's LGBT
friendliness um there's a there's a
sense in which if you're an American
Ally you're you're for this stuff and if
you're if you aren't for this stuff then
you're not an American Ally and you'll
be regime changed um so I think you know
to to the to the extent that people want
to present themselves as as America
friendly um this it it it's being it's
being adopted as as something you know
in a sort of Constantine like way yes I
if you've ever been to any uh cities in
America the number of churches which
actually are bedec in Rainbow Flags is
quite striking yeah it's it's
particularly the Unitarian universalists
yes yeah uh it's an absolutely
fascinating subject but we better wrap
it up there um I uh I thoroughly
recommend you all read Ed's piece which
is in the spectators Christmas edition
I'll wave it around uh and thank you
very very both very very much for coming
on to spectator TV and I wish you both a
very spiritual and highly religious
[Music]
Christmas